ai ai e a doença
olá pessoal de quem falar que sejam
muito bem vindos a ice1 bem ok um
estrago de que três jogos de grêmio
buscar três jogos diferentes ainda por
cima longe de que os dias contados na
barriga portanto qualquer susto eu bater
pode ser coisas daqui e vamos lá é com
certeza sabe quando você escreve zucollo
nati fica preso executado com tiros
então buscar estes três jogos de grande
que é preciso ajuda só porque acha que
vai acontecer
e se você for menor do que no canal
pessoal já se inscrevam até porque vai
ser muito viril agora e deixa muito leve
espírito que isso ajuda muito o canal a
atenção e buscar o uso original porque
já joguei inclusive eu não sei jogar não
consegue chegar a mim é muito difícil
mas eu achei que três jogos muito
prestígio grande tipo família e
provavelmente este vídeo vai ser longo
como vocês gostam portanto resolvido até
o final vai ser muito importante bolas
vão começar só o primeiro jogo em que
nós vamos ganhar o primeiro fama de
grande ms que ninguém não esquece de
ninguém nem sequer grande honra aos né e
survivor games é isso como podem ver a
igreja que também pode atacar mais
querido jackson e ela tá brava ela tá
brava está muito irritada quando ela
começar o gato lakers e tim wiese as que
já têm uma dificuldade normal
ah mas tem que pagar esse tabu que a não
ser buscar free - o povo agora já houve
volta grande e jangada que no novo né e
quer a ofender sair tudo bem está em 15
dias tudo que preciso e se na casa pelo
ovo qualquer coisa grammy é cleise é
melhor o tema luca é basicamente as
mesmas regras de grande então é só
escapar da casa os óculos ou olha aí
obviamente temos um frigorífico
espero que minha comida lá e me porque
os gráficos estão ó de que olga já com
os o pessoal já tem aqui na casa o time
já que um já dá pra jogar já o da
portugal já o erro agora sim eu sou um
profissional do jogo do guarani
ok e agora o que eu faço essa porta ou
essa bota tá muito megapixels não está
na gaveta em pando
ok vamos lá começar
eu vou vir aqui o o o lago nem vou me
esconder e que estava com ela posso
esconder que ele espera que seja o
motivo da rua
não pode o brasil está ali é só a greve
está muito podre mil e uma coisas
acontecendo agora já conheço o júlio já
começa muita coisa em troca qualquer
calma calma na hora que se inspira
expira deixa grande ir embora já foi
embora
o jogo tem um sinistro por agredir ou
até mesmo fechar a porta na cara sai
greve é porque deus é só botar no lugar
de hugo não acredito que ela está
confusa foi contra a porta a porta é
doida velha mostrar um pouco mais que
ela tira as casas posta dentro não vamos
jogar só em tv é maluca não vai do urso
isso é deixar um pouquinho e vamos
começar a ver que estas portas de um mal
aqui eu posso pensar em tudo eo que era
um sofá avançar e é isso que é uma pena
uma queda nas costas como é que isso não
estava em um estudo inédito que procurar
outro quarto
como assim eu fui ver o que está a
acontecer e ao lado e e avisam o quarto
e quando o quarto jogo pano pra
agradecer só que assim não consegui
saber se acreditar no quarto porque
o que o youtube revisou o outro muito
confuso ensino na posse já o que ela já
foi embora
observamos o agricultor nesta que é meio
televisão dawn o lomba mas não é muito
pouco assim não há cinco advogados
inclusive diário não queria noite vamos
lá
este jogo aqui eu não sei eu não sei mas
vamos aqui na porta o jacaré que
investia e isso é acusado na cabeça toma
aqui não tá todo torto
funciona assim
só que tenho que fazer já choveu só o
primeiro jogo o que equivale ao de um
dash
faça um comentário mas calma que ainda
pode surpreender que tentamos parar até
o fim vamos ver se eu consigo passar o
jogo vamos ver se torna mais
interessante mas no final passou após a
eleição só de 1 10 km entre categoria e
não subiu e vamos aproveitar para
explorar e que esta parte têm armas tem
uma tela aqui na paraíba os usuários não
dá ensinou a não conseguir porém isto é
muito bacana o jato no outro quarto
muito pânico o que ela faz vir eu vou
dar aqui um drible calma calma calma
acabou eu precisava pra baixo então eu
quero que ela vai abrir este ano um
quarto isso é esta é e agora vamos dar a
volta por cima ao aproveitar a volta eu
não sei se vou correr mais do que eu é
que a porta está fechada é caça cansa
cansa isso deixa deixa eu nem vou olhar
pra grane nem vou olhar só passa eu
passo hoje aqui um xarope my eu cheiro
forte e só pegando chorou e não sei o
que é uma granja
soma se a essa é a bruxa da branca nessa
isso isso isso isso isso e agora está
aqui uma porta aberta não é daqui eu tô
sentindo sentir calma ai ai ui ui a
transmil e andré é cantar you tube como
aquela bola parou no inferno tamanha
corre-corre em wall parede rochosa
língua ela pessoa preto como quando
aquela pessoa do aparelho não explicar
isto não sabemos que este jogo rock band
vamos lá ai ai meu coração palpita o
boicote já você acha que essa janela
abre não a entende em ok então vamos
tentar usar a mesma técnica eu vou
tentar atraí la para aqui não no eu não
era assim o que tem como hobby
vou ter que escolher basta que a outra
vez meu deus meu deus dos céus ó em
conta que o álbum tal vai bater contato
com o metal atingiu uma pessoa que sem
armas não só que sem uepa no senado e
ela conta que eles voltem já está bom é
que ela já tem uma grande ela já possa
ganhar já podem ganhar aqui mas não ela
vai contar e justiça
sua pele de 8 ou não no lombo e você
cuidado é eu sou bastante roxo calor tá
muito calor e sol calor e não conseguir
isto
alegrem se eu tenho que me adaptar pra
quem de pisco ganês sandy do df mas não
é só isso que eu tenho de voltar de
santos que defendeu bem 5 a 1 e chegou
ao o qual ela passou já por outro lado
isso mesmo acho muito gênio e agora tem
que encontrar uma ciné uma seda preta eu
já nem vou pegar a pulsão janeiro o
canal
ela ficou lá em cima é impossível ela
pulou eu já estava lá embaixo já já no
quarto já já na quarta filha dela e ela
ficou lá em cima é impossível ela usou
uma corda e puxa para cima como pessoa
vamos lá tentar outra vez não ela subir
a escada é sobre o lugar não é uma
inspiração o não da gestão que é alegre
o jogo nem usa internet não dá um sinal
bem poderiam não gostar mas justo né não
buscar num caminho sólido faz idéia é o
quinto dia portanto os óscares que um
jogo mas estou orgulhoso anunciou paraná
e se isso ajudasse o juiz mesmo é isso
mesmo
o bicho estava bem longe dela é algo
aqui só porque o jogo é mesmo um cara
dela como o grupo é toda a cara dela e
pela j
embaixo que você já fez um primeiro júri
de goiânia e dilma 10 comentei para o
acesso ao próximo jogo então nós vamos
ganhar o próximo foi no meio de grandes
chamas papa organismo cruzassem precisa
então é investir a roma luca atrás nós
vai ser o nosso papel nós eu vou o nosso
a bordo do módulo para ligar não
interessa quantas vezes se joga o jogo
vai ser uma experiência diferente ao
invés de 18 anos a quem vai pagar
basicamente eu tiver todas as vezes que
quiser steel que vai ser diferente então
vamos lá ver o que é que este o tempo já
o terceiro para lá e esse é o nosso
papel é isso
o solo de nick jonas só eu posso perder
os princípios encontrar chatos am a voz
dos tacos a evitar os obstáculos
what to forget flores o gauchão partir
na casa
será que eles tenham perdido em torno de
u tem que ter atenção ok eo resto
escapar açores
então mais uma vez eu tenho que ir para
casa e tem que ter atenção e essas
coisas todas
o objetivo é encontrar a chave então
vamos lá meu deus olha aí o papai já com
uma chave na mão e se ele tem uma arma
mais poderosa e sim não é um time bobo
leves em uma chave love
olha aí só completamente igual a grane
comissão de que já não costello rúa um
olhar pro pau e aí quem sabe o quanto eu
posso esconder uma fonte foge à ottawa
rocha está lá em cima e subiu dentro de
um quarto com assim ó próximo esconder
aqui há há há ok posso escolher basta as
mesas por exemplo tem um olhinho e se
encantar wells quando a cair então assim
assim já é menos complicada
ah ah mas eu não posso esconder nossas
mesas redondas aqui e aqui não consigo o
que é este jogo parece estar muito
melhor fato é a mesma estrutura de
qualidade em si está muito bom o ok
vamos lá continuar vou tentar subir o
assassino nem aí já que o espírito
arriscar a minha vida em cima eu sei que
eu vou aqui hoje uma casa próximo de
correr aqui embaixo também pode esconder
debaixo das camas rock está muito igual
a greve é um governo mais estranha é que
nós temos dentro do castelo é preciso
encontrar a chave precisa encontrar
muita gente e eu não consegui suportar
as fraquezas chave por esta porta caiu
pelo meio já são aquecidas
a yoki voltar a discutir o futebol o que
não é uma chave o martelo o o hotel
cachês em 2011 já tem uma vítima eu saí
encontro que alguém aí está ok
meu coração está a pintar muita emoção
ok então vamos aceitar que os lançou
embora calma quando e como anda o tio eu
andei precisamento se tem um do chão
parte e não posso entrar ali naquela
sala
ok vamos lá continua agora bailar
este jogo está muito melhor hoje a subir
vou subir 18 vídeos passageiro e no
espaço dela
a porta atingiu até mesmo entre na mesma
sala senão da actriz que está hessel
atestada em excesso aos cinemas para
este jogo quero muito aqui nos filhos e
isso ajuda muito a conquistar a atenção
eu sei que isso não vai ajudar muito mas
do chico é a mesma e para casa minha
barriga já está melhor tempo já anotou
cinco tentos a vontade de fazer é que o
qual estou sabendo
conversamos exemplo para lá continuar
o neco tocou nenhuma maneira
não posso usar isso faço um pouco de
barulho
trombetta um avião subiu acho que o o
quinto encontro enquanto aí é um martelo
aí eu vou dar como até a lua vai o kit
huse e ir e tony que eu posso usar isso
é para roubar os que se fazem bons copos
em cima da mesa e ouviu então se eu
encostar nos jogos já exporta em um novo
e vem atrás de mim o que está muito mais
complexa do jogo muito mais complexo e
se gosta e não gosta da categoria é
heaven anel já sem o hotel fui curtir
jatos ou não ouviu eu estou muito medo
de onda passou a lhe disse eu estava
aqui o vôo
lembra muito o personagem do atleta vai
fazer isso em cima da chave agora é
preocupante e não deve ser lá em baixo
porque este show aqui partido tem que
ter muito cuidado com isso
o único que tinha entrado aqui num
clique
o trecho da rua nova e desloca para
suzano shopping
não não posso usar a chave aqui como
assim eu tenho a chave não é preso na
porta
hoje não funciona eo que não funciona
sério e espero ganhar ainda outra chave
calmas beijo tapar ele falou que só eu
acho que joguei bem o suficiente este
jogo então comecei em baixo que vocês
acham jogo dois de uma vez quando val e
no fim do vídeo vou fazer a minha
avalição também para lá só o próximo
jogo ora lá pessoal e só musiquinha
funda é que o benin o exterior
a grandiosa história e sei lá é tudo meu
nome 121 só cara de granito é muito
possível tinha visto aquilo né
aí parece um passe bem e tudo que eu
acho que numa prisão então bora lá
começar a jogar play em vários níveis
eu achava que não será fácil e pró o
[Música]
animax está ausente escapar desta casa e
seu objetivo totalmente igual à grande
ok só entende quem não sabe o que é isso
é uma único recusando muito de preço
ciclópico de um só nome é muito louco
não gostar muito de dor só se você
estiver em um site de fãs vocês vão
perceber tudo isto aqui são muito mais
envolventes é assim que eu me sinto
próximo já sabe que em alguma coisa é
porque 99 é muito bom mas vamos lá
ok vamos sair da cama porque não me já
saiu
[Música]
1 eu consegui escapar de mong há mesmo
na cara dela eu como bastante é muito
rápido
ok meu deus meu deus dos céus
lá eu vou tentar a escalada do mesmo só
vai pra trás por uma porta só faixa
preta gil é ser mulher muito perigosa
para isso e isso é triste sem alguém mas
nunca com ou sem vento e maré humana que
é muito engraçado esse episódio não vou
deixar entrar eu não to love ou se não
há um senão vamos o tabu gado
supostamente eu não poderia passar pela
porta nós vamos continuar a falar por
uma primeira tentativa tempo que separa
o bairro mas vamos lá sua vida
[Música]
o shopping está focada em uma música
típica dos tempos de fundo
foi uma música do tempo hawking se lá o
que é isso
ah ah ah eu estava debaixo daquela época
eu não tocou e agora o google como assim
não da antiga julgar julgou do jogador
só comida embaixo de onde é show 3d o
médico pode já começar com pontuação
baixa já viram mourinho já pela parte
então eu pensei que ninguém olha eu vou
dizer porque vamos correr muito rápido
no trecho sul vai sair claro não vai
agora não veio com ó assim não dá pra
jogar ovo não arriscar a gol já sei onde
vamos parar eu passar por este lado e
pensar que eu estou lá e vamos pensar
nós por aqui um lado não há muita
estratégia muito olha pra isso é uma
mulher muito fácil e tem um taco de
beisebol com bandeira de um tac ferro
está aqui tem um taco de madeira e é um
homem supostamente super poderosa com o
unilever que o nosso hotel sangue
esta porta grande
muito do que eu escolhi ana deus dos
céus dos céus na memória a múmia vai
embora chorando aqui você não investir
aqui você não paga renda da casa
mas embora a pagar um euro pela legenda
aqui do meu lado que é isso é uma prisão
o jovem fosse daí o pagar um euro ainda
acha que manda aqui alguma coisa ainda
por cima está sem luz em casa foi roubo
gol ou não não pela música
[Música]
o do sul rs
eu saio daqui moeda lá não estava no
banho sai melhor
rio ainda banho e se já da cama da cama
[Música]
ou da pepsi apurou o editor de texto
estava a abrir esta tv e eu estou que eu
posso achar que possa haver uma chave
micha achar a chave aqui dentro não
deixa apanhar pegar o garfo juntar o
gato ta no garçom 0 lecce enquanto
actual está a funcionar isso não há
funcionários que já tinham produção
olha a instituição funciona uma escola
o união foi doado e ouvido lado no filme
de que caraças não é muito assustador
ser o assassino mia faz muito barulho
aquela foi o de belém entrou ao vivo
embora a mulher é grande já que embora
eu voltar a cair em um trecho 2 16 h á
tua bunda oec de saúde não há de ser a
tentativa com as curvas aumento muito
contentes capa desta múmia que é só uma
criança e eu ainda continua a assombrar
o malvino treino pois o meu deus muito
bom e só estes foram os três jogos do
grêmio três formatos que os ganhões
quiserem que eu faça mais vídeos deste
tipo com vários jogos dentro de um vídeo
que tem embaixo e agora vamos lá as
eleições primeiro jogo eu acho que
tentava se razoável estava muito podre
inclinadas em imagem e tal mas eu acho
que de uma vez fui tipo 4 mas quatro é
justo nem com o segundo jogo a minha
compulsão de uma vez vou dizer sr
qualidade até estava melhor e tal o chão
por dia têm imensa de interações com 10
desde a mudança estava um pouco melhor
do que o primeiro jogo mas também estava
assim uma importante não é isso aí
e agora isso tem o pessoal apesar de ter
estado e apesar de ter passado tantas em
lei porém o vasco dar 20 10 5 então é o
primeiro jogo com 45 tio concede preciso
com cinco nesse tempo eu gostava liceu
embaixo só quebrou perceber qual é o que
pediu para ser mais gostam e sportv
o estado fique bem e até a próxima
[Música]